if the trip home takes 39 minutes at
what time does chris have to leave in
order to be home by a quarter after six
a quarter after six so let's draw a
timeline and then think about what has
to happen here this is at least how i
need to visualize it in order to solve
this problem and i'm going to do the
hours before 6 and after 6. so i'll
start at 5 and i'll go up to 7 just to
make sure that we capture everything
i can draw a straighter line than that
so let me draw it a little bit
straighter
it's still not perfect but it'll do the
job
so let's say that this is five o'clock
this is six o'clock
and they don't specify whether it's am
or pm
and this is seven o'clock
seven o'clock
they tell us he has to be home by a
quarter after six so what is a quarter
after six
well it's going to be a quarter of the
way between six and seven o'clock so
this would be half of the way between
six and seven o'clock and then a quarter
would be half of that so this would be a
quarter after six and if we wanted to
specify what time a quarter after six is
a quarter of the way between six and
seven we know there's 60 minutes in an
hour so this distance is 60 minutes a
quarter of 60 is 15 minutes so this time
right over here is 6
15 and that's when chris has to be home
now they tell us that the cr the trip
home takes 39 minutes so he would have
have to he would have had to have left
39 minutes before this in order to get
home at 6 15.
so let's go 39 minutes before this to
figure out the time that he would have
to leave in order to be home by 6 15.
so what is 39 minutes what is 39 minutes
before
before 6 15. now the way my brain
processes it i like to think about well
how much time how much time does it take
to get to the hour and then how much
time do you have left to kind of go
before the hour
so this part right over here this part
right over here is 15 minutes if you go
back 15 minutes from 6 15 and go to 6
o'clock that was 15 minutes
so we've already gone 15 minutes back if
we go to six o'clock and then how many
minutes do we have left to go back well
we went 15 of the 39
39 minus 15
is 24
so we have to go another 24 minutes
before the hour so this time right over
here this time right over here is 24
minutes
24 minutes
before
before
six o'clock
before six o'clock and once again the
way we figured it out well look going
from 6 15 if you go 15 minutes back you
get to 6 o'clock we have to go 39 so we
have 24 left so then we have to go 24
minutes before six o'clock
but 24 minutes before six o'clock would
be how many minutes after five o'clock
well once again we know that there's 60
minutes in an hour so what's 60 minus 24
let me do it right over here
so
60
minus 24 is equal to 36
and you could either do that in your
head or you could say hey look you know
i could maybe borrow here this is a 10
this is a 5 or a regroup 10 minus 4 is 6
5 minus 2 is 3. the way my brain does it
is i say oh you know 60 minus 30 would
get me to 30 but then i have to subtract
i or 60 minus 20 would get me 240 and
then i need to subtract another four
more to get to 36 but either way that if
we're talking about 24 minutes before
six o'clock that's the equivalent to 36
minutes
minutes
after
after five o'clock
so this time right over here is 5
5 36
so when they say what time does chris
have to leave in order to be home by a
quarter after 6
5 36.